they've said out loud that they believe
they're a superior species to us those
Elites you're talking Klaus you named
them he he has quoted and him and his
scientists and his crew of people they
have quoted saying that they are a
higher power human than we are we we are
the basic human they are the Superhuman
that's their belief there's about three
thousand four thousand people in the
world that believe they are another
species above us you and me and that's
why they think they're allowed to just
do what they're doing talk about putting
chips in us and whatever whatever they
want to do right you talk about the
world economic Forum they believe
they're a superior uh human breed than
we are it's the elite and the pleb which
is basically since the dawn of the time
there's been the leaders and the slaves
and then it was the leaders and the
civilians and then it was the leader the
elites and the common man and then
there's the better man but who doesn't
want to be smarter better than someone
else right you play basketball against
someone you think you're better than
them right everyone thinks they just
think they're better than us but is that
a fact that is not a fact that's just
their opinion